gotta admit i was surprised that wand
division decided to go with a malcolm in
the middle homage for their 2000
sitcom cause there was an absolutely
perfect line they could have used if
they had gone the scrubs are out
hello internet welcome to film theory
where wandavision is so nice
we're covering it twice with so much
craziness happening in this incredible
disney plus series i'm doing my best to
keep you all up to speed but with our
production schedule and this show's time
jumping mechanic sometimes feels like
i'm decades behind
ah would that our editors had the speed
powers of quicksilver how was it that
pietro got his powers again he
volunteered to be experimented on
by hydra alright edit team listen up
have i got a vacation plan for you guys
so our last theory on wandavision was
pretty much confirmed within 24 hours of
us releasing it the fact that wanda is
the big bad of her own show
despite the fact that she may not know
how she's doing it the fact that she's
most likely piloting around vision's
dead body
the fact that she had been to sword
headquarters before the whole thing
started and the fact that this would be
disney's first major chance to open the
door to the x-men i know our hit ratio
on the channel ain't always the greatest
for prediction theories but
man that was like the home run of
episodes now we're just waiting on the
big reveal that sword dude over here is
the show's real big bad and the fact
that the kids will either disappear or
be taken by sword before the end of the
series but let's just stop for a minute
to talk about that touchy little subject
of the kids
by now one thing should be pretty clear
wanda maximov's twin sons billy and
tommy are a major part of both the wand
division story
and the mcu as a whole but where have
all the other kids in town gone in
episode 5 vision raises this exact
question
wonder why are there no other children
in western oh sure in episode 6 we see
them running around for halloween
festivities but we also don't get
ourselves an answer as to where they
were before and why they're only showing
up now
where were you hiding all these kids up
till now i assume they were all just
sleeping peacefully in their beds no i
you're always the empathetic twin i
don't i didn't now that could certainly
be wanda deflecting in an attempt to
deny that she's controlling the world or
more likely
she doesn't actually have a full
explanation for this
as we heard in episode five do you
really think that i
am controlling everything that i i am
somehow in charge of
everybody in west view and again here in
episode six i don't know
how i did it i only remember feeling
completely alone so today i wanted to
dig into all the kids stuff what's the
deal with west view's children and how
does it all relate back to tommy
billy the show's ending and the reality
of the mcu moving forward
if you're unfamiliar with these two
characters billy and tommy have had a
weird life in the original comics canon
billy and tommy were just
aspects of scarlet witch's belief their
babysitter a 500 plus year old witch
noticed that when wanda's life was in
jeopardy or when she was just distracted
the kids would
inexplicably cease to exist despite this
they still somehow managed to inherit
their powers from their mother
and uncle you heard that right their
uncle please don't ask me to write a
theory about how that one happened and
they eventually grow up to become the
superheroes wiccan
and speed eventually wanda learns that
her kids are fake and her mind gets
wiped so that she forgets about him
until of course she doesn't anymore and
then goes sicko mode on the universe
but consider this in one division billy
and tommy are really unique thus far
because they're the only living things
to come from nothing
it's an easy scene to overlook because
it was in an episode full of huge
moments but in episode 5
we got this those
pants are 87 kevlar it's not an illusion
wanda is rewriting reality wanda didn't
just conjure up new clothes for monica
she rearranged the materials in the
kevlar jacket that monica was wearing to
create a new
period appropriate costume what's more
when wanda wanted to create this
fictional reality she first had to steal
vision's body vision was mostly software
interfacing with the mind stone and his
body
well certainly a marvel of technology
was not really an essential part of what
made him
him wanda however needed vision's body
to complete her act within the confines
of the town
she's not creating matter out of nothing
to make this reality
it's all coming from somewhere looks
like someone learned a thing or two from
watching full metal alchemist
if one wishes to obtain something
something of equal value must be given
this is the law of equivalent exchange
for further proof look at when wanda
herself leaves the bubble
unlike monica's clothes wanda is wearing
her normal outfit when she leaves the
hex and while it's not super clear
because marvel did a good job of keeping
it out of focus there doesn't appear to
be a wedding ring on her left hand
her ring of course was something that
was conjured out of nothingness in
episode 1
but because it's made of nothing it
shouldn't exist out in the real world
when she
exits the bubble so what then does this
mean for wiccan and speed are they
conjured from nothing and therefore
can't exist outside of the bubble or if
they
are real what are they being conjured
from well we know that they're gonna
have to be real eventually
not because of anything in the show but
because of the wider business around the
marvel machine
see there's just a whole slew of new
young heroes that are going to be
hitting the big and small screens over
the next two years cassie lang
ant-man's daughter just got recast from
endgame indicating that marvel is seeing
her as a bigger character going forward
literally as it's likely that she'll
eventually become jai
ant girl or stature as cassie lang tends
to do in the comics the hawkeye
disney plus series is centered around
clint passing the torch to kate bishop
and later this year miss marvel is
supposed to get her own
disney plus show and all of this is
without mentioning spider-man and some
of the other long-shot guesses that are
coming down the pipe
this lineup alone would create a solid
foundation for a new team up and another
giant crossover event the young avengers
and who are critical members of the
young avengers
wanda's kids wiccan and speed with
wiccan being especially prominent you
see
wiccan was something of the face of
lgbtq representation in the avengers for
a while and it looks like marvel is
gearing up for more representation in
the mcu moving forward
in an interview with siriusxm joe russo
director of endgame
an actor who cameoed as the first openly
gay character on screen
said this who else is gay uh we're gonna
find out you know there is a
gay character coming up in uh one of
their films i think
kevin will make that announcement with
wiccan just becoming a prominent
character in the universe he is a prime
candidate to be
that new lgbtq character which means the
boys
must be real in some capacity here but
how
what are they made out of if moving
forward they have to survive
outside of wanda's protective bubble
well part of me really
really wanted wanda to have used
westview's children
as the raw materials to create her own
kids but uh
it seemed like it might be a bit too
dark for disney and in episode six
seeing her children alongside other kids
from the town kind of shot that theory
down prematurely but if the biological
building blocks aren't naturally in
westview
where then are they all coming from our
answer i think
comes from science in episode 4 the
character darcy throws out some
scientific mumbo-jumbo about wanda's
reality bubble
my equipment registered an extremely
high level of cmbr
that's relic radiation dating back to
the big bang yeah now that sounds like
the sort of stuff that a writer's room
would make up to have a character like
darcy sound smart but cmbr
is a legit thing that may just give us
the proof that we need to crack the
whole wandavision mystery wide open you
see
cmbr or cosmic microwave background
radiation is a faint glow of
electromagnetic radiation left over from
the big bang
the initial discovery of cmbr was made
when some technicians working on an
extremely powerful radio receiver
couldn't understand where the faint
static they detected was coming from as
scientific american explains it quote
it is the residual heat of creation the
afterglow of the big bang
streaming through space these past 14
billion years and the most interesting
thing about it is that it falls on earth
from
every direction with practically uniform
intensity which is why when darcy picks
up a whole lot of it coming from wanda's
bubble it's as amazing as darcy makes it
out to be
the only reason that that would happen
is if there was a birth of a whole new
universe within the realm
of that bubble just like the big bang
created the universe and sent out cmbr
for billions of years afterwards it
seems like
wanda is legitimately doing the same
thing she's not just reshaping this one
reality she is tapping into
another universe which is sending out
its own cmbr waves it's important to
remember that the mcu wanda has her
origins with the mind stone after
unspecified experimentation with the
mind stone
maximoff gained telekinetic and
telepathic abilities which uh i gotta
admit it's kind of creepy when you
consider that the mind stone basically
created her
and now she's married to the empty husk
where the mind stone used to be
and we've seen that wanda's had to take
some massive shortcuts to make this
reality work like the stores for mops
locksmithing flooring and plumbing in
short wanda is a first generation
playstation 4 trying its hardest to
render cyberpunk 2077. while she might
be able to get
most of the basic pieces in place
there's certainly a lot of wonkiness
going on and episode 6 starts pointing
this out explicitly we're treated to
these terrifying shots of citizens on
the periphery of wanda's attention being
forced to endlessly repeat their actions
while tears stream down their face
these people near the edge of town
they're barely moving
are they alive children it would seem
are specifically harder for wanda to
control
kids can't control them
no matter how hard you try especially
her own kids she can't put them to sleep
she's unable to stop them from aging
themselves up i suspect
it's because they're not her magic
between the cmbr waves and her inability
to control the kids i get the sense that
they're from
another universe that they've been
pulled into this reality by
wanda's subconscious or some other more
nefarious source that's using wanda
need more proof pietro remember wanda
can't just create
people she needed vision's body and
westview to use him and she rearranged
monica's clothes rather than conjuring
new ones so where did pietro's body come
from
well if we assume he is who he says he
is and isn't some sort of undercover
agent
hey i'm not some stranger
and i'm not your husband you can talk to
me that is just a weirdly suspicious
line there pietro it leaves our only
option as him being pulled in from
another reality and in this case i don't
think it's a coincidence that the
episode pietro first appears in takes
place between the late 80s and early 90s
that time period is the same time period
in which dark phoenix the final mainline
fox x-men movie took place
new mutants accepted but that's kind of
a whole separate thing the mcu's wanda
and pietro
born in 1989 would either be unborn or
babies when this episode was taking
place
so she couldn't just grab an alternate
reality version of her mcu brother
if wanda wanted a brother in her weird
time-shifted universe he would need to
have been born
way before then like ideally in the late
50s so that the ages would match up
in the fox universe quicksilver was born
in 1956 which would make him a perfect
late 20s early 30s to match wanda's age
by the time they hit the late 80s early
90s
wanda's powers subconsciously found her
a perfect candidate a brother that would
temporarily match her age as she's flash
forwarding
through the decades but with this being
a quick silver from a different universe
it would explain why wanda in episode 6
doesn't remember pietro's childhood
story exactly the way he tells it worse
than the costumes mom made is the year
we got typhus
[Music]
that's not exactly how i remember it
would also explain why there's a 1950s
era nuclear propaganda poster on the
wall next to the old woman's house in
the flashback clip how does pietro still
remember getting shot to death in wanda
vision if he's from a different universe
yeah don't really have a solid
explanation for that one but here's the
thing
i just don't see a world where the
multiverse doesn't get mixed in
as a result of wand division either all
of these characters wiccan
speed and pietro are the creations of
wanda and they just disappear at the end
of the show
leading to wanda ripping open the
multiverse to find living versions of
them to reclaim her happiness and
jumpstart the next phase of the mcu
or they are all real and it's revealed
that she's unwittingly pulling them in
from other universes since you know she
can't just have conjured them out of
nothing or heck there's always option
number three maybe disney went real big
brain and my initial impulse was right
wanda used the children of the town
and remixed them to create her own two
new bundles of joy it's a long shot it
is
super dark but man would that be a
shocking twist to put a cap on such an
exciting series
you want a powerful new villain for the
next phase of movies doing something
like that would definitely fit the bill
but hey that's just a theory a film
theory and if you're interested in
getting more marvel theories make sure
you've hit that subscribe button we do
them all year round even when there's
nothing to talk about in the marvel
universe for instance on screen right
now is my related theory to this one
about how thor
is also signaling the coming collapse of
the multiverse you heard that right
wanda is opening up the multiverse and
thor is shutting the whole thing down
that theory is clickable on screen right
now so make sure you check that one out
if you missed it and i'll see you all
next week